tada
Lily wachowski was all smiles as she
picked up her GLAAD Media Award Saturday
the event marked her first public
appearance since coming out as
transgender how does it feel to be here
uh well I haven't puked yet so that's
good
I wasn't appropriate to be here tonight
and show some face for the for the
organization um well they helped me uh
getting my getting the word out for me
they were extremely protective they do
such great work so I felt not an
obligation but I wanted to give back and
I gotta ask you is there a sense of
relief do you feel free oh yeah people
ask me if I'm happy but you know
happiness it's not a finish line that
you cross in your life it's a journey
yeah sure but you know I'm speaking my
truth and I'm living my truth and that's
important for everybody to be able to do
that since her announcement Lily says
the support has been overwhelmingly
positive especially from her sister and
directing partner Lana who is also a
transgender woman there's a critical eye
being cast back on Lana's in my work
through the lens of our transness this
is a cool thing because it's an
excellent reminder that art is never
static she pushed all these um all the
fence posts out and so in a lot of ways
I was just you know following in her
footsteps
you know and this it was almost like she
had her snow plowed and all these
channels opened up for me and while the
ideas of identity and transformation are
critical components in our work the
bedrock that all ideas rest upon is love